I've just been briefed by the
commissioner and the Assistant
Commissioner of the Metropolitan Police
about the events at London Bridge this
afternoon and while this is an ongoing
investigation the police can confirm
that this was a terrorist incident and
clearly my thoughts are first my
thoughts are first with the emergency
services with the police the bravery
that they showed in going towards danger
as they do I also want to pay tribute to
the extraordinary bravery of those
members of the public who physically
intervened to protect the lives of
others and for me they represent the
very best of our country and I thank
them on behalf of of all of our country
I think we're all very saddened also to
learn that some people have been injured
in this event and our sympathies are
very much with them and with their loved
ones
clearly the Metropolitan Police are
continuing their investigations and I
can assure you and assure everyone that
anybody involved in this crime in these
attacks will be hunted down and will be
brought to justice and I think the
message that we send to them and anyone
associated with this type of attack is
one that will be familiar and that is
that this country will never be cowed or
divided or intimidated by this sort of
attack and our values our British values
will prevail Prime Minister have you
learned more from your briefings with
senior officers about the suspect and
the background to this incident with or
not you're able to share that with us
now well there is a certain amount that
the police are able to share with us at
the moment but it is not yet entirely
clear and they're not at a stage where
it's possible to go public but what I
can say is that I here in number 10 we
will continue to be having meetings and
consultations as the evening goes on is
it your understanding that the immediate
danger
following from this incident has passed
with the killing of this suspect well to
the best of our knowledge the incident
has been contained but you know I pay
tribute again to the work of the police
and emergency services and what they in
what they've done but I would urge
everybody of course to be to be vigilant
and one cannot help but think back to
what happened in in 2017 in the same
part of the city and I hope very much
that people will be able as fast as
possible
to to go about their normal business and
just finally this happened of course in
the middle of a general election
campaign will campaigning continue as
normal
well I've obviously stopped by
campaigning for this evening but we'll
be we'll be reviewing the matter in the
course of next few hours